>>presenter: Good afternoon, everyone. Welcome
to AuthorsGoogle New York presentation. This
is Albert-Laszlo Barabasi, a Hungarian scientist.
He is the former Emil T. Hofmann professor
at the University of Notre Dame and dis-,
current Distinguished Professor and Director
of Northeastern University Center for Complex
Network Research and associate member of the
Center for Cancer Systems Biology at the Dana
Farber Cancer Institute at Harvard University.
He's here today to talk about his current
book, "Bursts", which probably has direct
applications for all of us here at Google.
So, without further ado, Dr. Barabasi.
[applause]
>>Albert: Thank you and thanks for the opportunity
of being here. So, well, let's just start
easy in that respect and I wanna show you--
if I can get technological-- a video that
I just discovered, essentially, last week
by somebody giving a talk. So, I stole it.
And what you see here, this is what I call,
what the original title is "Good Morning",
and it's a visualization of when people say
"good morning" around the globe. So, essentially,
it's coming from Twitter and what they have
done is that every time somebody, somebody
tweets "good morning," they color code it
in real time and what you end up, like the
green is like an early good morning, the yellow
is like 9am good morning at the local time
and then black are those people who say good
morning at the really odd time.
[laughter]
So, and if you just kind of look at it, you
can see how the morning comes around the globe
and how it really spreads and as a wave goes
through the US, like the, the orange line
goes through US as, as 9am passes by and,
and on one hand it is beautiful and the other
one it's, it appears to be completely useless
because who really cares about when people
say "good morning?"
[laughter]
But, on the other hand, it actually powers,
shows the power of what you can do with data
today. What you can do with this massive amount
of data that is emerging about human behavior.
And, of course, being at Google here today
I don't have to preach the power of data because
Google is really about data in that respect.
But it also shows how much data we can actually
cover about what we do essentially, on a daily
basis. And I'm a physicist and which means
I'm a natural scientist and, and -- which
means that I believe that natural phenomena
can be understood, described, quantified,
predicted and controlled. And no one would
find anything questionable about that statement.
That's what scientists are supposed to do
and that's how scientists are supposed to
believe to drive their work. What, however,
if we replace natural phenomena with humans?
And if we read the sentence together, then
it says humans are supposed to be understood,
described, quantified, predicted and controlled
and that's obviously a very scary statement.
[laughter]
So, I mean, we don't have to panic, of course.
That's the good news because the, the, -- there's
little secret that we don't really talk about
in science is, is that the fact that the scientific
revolution that really determines our life
has really stopped at the border of natural
sciences. It never really reached us humans.
And what I mean by that? I mean that we have
no problem predicting where an electron will
go, but we have -- but we cannot foresee electronic
crisis or, kind of emerging financial crisis
and so on. We have no problem turning on and
off a gene, essentially, in a cell, but we
have serious difficulties foreseeing wars
and battles and major crisis and so on. And
the reason for that is very simple. There
is a fundamental difference between humans
and bacteria, or, or other kind of natural
organisms because bacteria don't get really
annoyed at you when you put them under the
microscope. And the moon will never sue you
for landing a space craft on its face, but--
[laughter]
on the other hand, none of us really would
like to submit ourselves to that detailed
data collection that we really submit objects
of na-, of the study of natural sciences;
trying to know about them everything all the
time. And what I'm trying to do today is to
tell you a bit that this is about to change.
And it's gonna, and it's good change essentially
in a very profound way. Now, I mentioned prediction.
In order to make predictions, essentially,
you need data; lots of data. Anyone who tells
you that they can make any prediction without
data are either palm readers or business consultants.
[laughter]
So, when it comes to humans essentially, what
is really changing is that we started to have
data. And you know very well the kind of data
I'm talking about. Every time we send an email,
we leave some digital breadcrumb about our
social links, about interests and so on. Our
bank knows our ability to pay for things,
our tastes, our willingness to pay for certain
things and where we shop for. And, and our
mobile phone company knows where we are and
how me move around and, and so on. And so
we often don't choose to think about it. But
at the end of the day that we are under multiple
microscopes that will record, in real time,
what we do and from these digital breadcrumbs,
we actually, one can re-, recover a person's
life with almost minute resolution. So, when
it comes to the book Burst, what I tried to
achieve here is to, to kind of talk about
the fundamental changes that are happening
thanks to this huge amount of data that is
emerging about human behavior. There are lots
of aspects of this data. One of them is privacy
aspects and I'm sure being at Google you know
exactly what I'm talking about. But the book,
even though it mentions privacy, is not about
privacy. It's about the laboratory that really
our society is becoming, thanks to this huge
amount of data that is being automatically
collected about all of us and about its revealing
power to understand human behavior. Now, when
it comes to human behavior, we have to realize
that why -- I have a fundamental question
to ask is that why would a physicist care
about human behavior? And let me kind of rephrase
that question. Why would you listen to a physicist--
[laughter]
talking about human behavior or brain science,
instead of listening to sociologists or to
a brain scientist or somebody like that? And
the truth is that, yes, we in physics started
to care about human behavior, but our real
interest and my real interest really is in
understanding complex systems. And there are
a bunch of complex systems out there that
are worthy of scientific interest. The brain
is one of them. The economy is another one.
The human cell is another one and computer
systems is yet another one. But what is happening
the last years is that really, the society's
becoming the one where we can get the most
data about the behavior of the individual
components. The type of data that is really
emerging about what we do--all of us on a
daily basis--would be equivalent of knowing
every, what every single neuron of mine does
in real time. Or, would be equivalent of knowing
what every single gene of mine does, essentially,
in real time because there's individual data
collected about each individual; about their
activity patterns, mobility patterns and so
on. So, so when, what, if you wanna be pragmatic
and you believe that complex systems behave
in a similar fashion, then you wanna go in
a direction where you have the most data and
where you can make the most advances. And
in the last five, ten years, human society
is becoming the archetypical complex system
that we can really study in real time. So,
I mean, this is a long pursuit for, at least
for me. It started with our studies on networks
and some of you may have actually seen my
earlier book, "Linked", where I talked about
how people are connected and how components
of a complex system, generally, are connected.
How genes connect to each other, how computers
connect to each other and how you characterize
this large network that emerges from that.
And then, of course, the second step of this
pursuit is to go from the structure, the network
to the, the dynamics of when things happen
and how, how do we understand in time, the
type of events that take place in a complex
system and that's really the, the pursuit
and the goal of "Burst" in that respect. Now,
when I wrote "Burst" actually, I had a couple
of goals in mind. And one of them had to do
with how the book should look like. If you
write to a general audience, particularly
about science, there are a couple of clichés
that you are supposed to respect. First of
all is that you are supposed to spill all
the big ideas in the first chapter, so just
in case you never had the patient, the patience
to go all the way to the end, you haven't
really missed anything. So, you can stop at
the end of chapter 1. And, and also kind of
the chapters have to be a standalone so that,
once again, if you, if you feel that you stop
in the middle of the book you can still go
to a cocktail party and chat about reading
the book, itself. So, I kind of, when I wrote
"Burst", I said, "Let's, let's try to do something
different in a sense that if you don't have
any of these expectations that I described
from the novel, to the contrary, if you get
to the end of the novel and there's nothing
surprising that really builds on what happened
before, then you are somewhat disappointed."
So, in a way, I built essentially the book
to read as a narrative that evolves in time
and, and builds on each other and I can tell
you that much that, unless you read it to
the end, you will really not find out along
the way what hap-, what happens because some
of the big questions that I'm asking are really
kind of addressed fully only to the end and,
and they are kind of big turns in the, in
the story as we move along. But let me give
you also kind of an insider connect to "Burst",
which is like because it has a couple of different
lines of narratives that are moving together
and the first narrative has to do with what
I call "Hasan." This is a picture of Hasan
and Hasan is an artist. He's a, he's a media
installation artist, depending on how you
wanna define him, but one of the reason that
actually became interesting to us is because
something interesting happened to me after
September 11th, that is, after travelling
around Africa--and he travels a lot, I mean,
he travels so much essentially that he has
a 96 pages thick passport because he needs
that many pages to fit all the pass-, all
the stamps that, to the countries he travels
to--and so, he was actually, pulled off the
plane once he returned to US after September
11th and was questioned by the FBI in Detroit
and that started essentially a hiatus step.
Kind of lasted about six months that eventually
ended with lie detector tests and he has spent
many, many hours in the FBI offices; never
being really arrested, never being really
officially processed, but nevertheless, constantly
harassed about what are his activities. It
turned out that the reason why they arrested
him was very simple--because he happened to
have a, a storage box in Florida that he closed
down just right after September 11. So, the
local owners of the storage facility looked
at him and said, "You know, you know, September
11th, we know that Florid-, people from Florida
are [ ] the training happened there. This
guy's called Hasan Alaji. Hasan Alaji, he
has brownish skin, so what could he be?"
[laughter]
[Albert laughs]
So and that really kind of put him underwater
for about six months and much longer, actually,
so certain activity continues today. But what
is interesting about him is not what happened
to him, because he's not alone; it happened
to many people. What is interesting about
him is that how he reacted to these events.
And the, after some of the, some of the visits
to the FBI, he was asked essentially to every
time to reveal where he goes internationally,
partly for his own safety so he can come back
to the US and so on, and eventually he decided
that he will start revealing this information
publically. So, if you, he has a website that
I haven't yet connected to Internet here,
but the point is that if you go to his website,
trackingtransients.com, you can find out in
real time where he is precisely. You can get
pictures of the environment where he is. You
can get, essentially, not only for where he
is now, but all his past for the last six,
seven years. You can get pictures of all the
meals he ate, all the bathrooms he's visited,
all the expenses he ever made, all the flight
numbers he ever took, pretty much all his
life, essentially, spelled out there. So,
now you parti-, perhaps can understand why
it's interesting for us because he's a person
whose activity is publically known. It's available
to everybody because he chose to disclose
his life, the way he thinks about it, by disclosing
all his activities and putting it out to everybody,
it becomes worthless because the value of
the information is based that some people
have it and others don't and that's where
the value is derived from and when everybody
has access to the information the value really
drops. And, and in his case, he thought that
the value for the FBI for information about
him becomes worthless if it's available to
everybody. And he also kind of tracks himself
in the behalf of the FBI, the way he thinks
about it. But, as a result, we know a lot
about him and one of the things I do in the
book is that we actually analyze his trajectory,
his, his habits and we compare it to the habits
of millions of other individuals to try to
understand whether is he really unusual or
is he normal? Was the FBI actually right arresting
him for, for because he was, the reason he
was arrested was for irregular travel patterns
as well. And, and was, was the FBI right doing
so or he's relatively ordinary and there are
some actually interesting surprises as we
analyzed him as they come along in the book.
So, that's the first story line that we follow
across the book and only at the end of the
book we actually get to understand what's
happened to him all the way here today. The
second story line I call it 1514. And it really
refers to an event that started in Rome in
1513 at the Papal election and then it went
into a big crusades that started, that started
from Hungary and spread to Transylvania and,
of course, one of the reasons this was somewhat
interesting for me--and I knew a bit more
about it because I happened to be born in
Transylvania so I'm somewhat more familiar
with, with the events over there--but why
is this interesting? The reason why this event
is interesting, from the perspective of the
book, is because at the certain moment at
the beginning of the events, some person gets
up and says, "I know exactly what's going
to happen." And he gives, essentially, a prophecy
saying that if you guys do with these decisions
and the decision is about starting a crusade
or not starting a crusade, then, then this
will be the outcome of the events. It will
lead some really blott-, bloody battles, in
which you're gonna be ending up, ending up
on the shorter end of the table. And, and
the question that I ask through this particular
story is that was he right making that prediction?
And how could somebody in 1513 make a prediction
about the events that will actually happen
during the next six months. And, in general,
using this one as a, as a starting point,
can we really make predictions about events
that are of such magnitude as, as they appear
in history books and so on? And the beauty
about events happening in 1514 that we know
exactly what the outcome is, of course. But
I think that the story itself is very fascinating
and very much ties into the, the world pursuit
of the book about predictability of human
behavior. And the third aspect of the book,
of course, is the science. And I, the code
is called "Bursts" because the bursts certainly
refers to an activity pattern that we all
beha- that we all follow. And if you look
at anybody's activity pattern in real time--when
do we send emails, when do we make phone calls,
so when do we browse the Web--and I challenge
you for those of you have access to data like
that to look at it whether it's the case or
not. I'm sure it's going to be true because
we looked at lots of data in that respect.
These events are not random in time, but they
are conglomerated into bursts. That is, I
have short periods of time when I send lots
of emails out and then long periods where
I don't have, get a chance to do any. And
then follows another burst of activity when
it comes to my email. Same for phone calls,
same for, even essentially, sex, same for,
same for visiting the libraries or certain
locations and so on. So one of the things
we notice in the last kind of decade is that
really human activity is not entirely random,
but there -- it has these conglomerations
into these short bursts. And most important
the timing of these events actually follows
very precise laws that we call "power laws".
And that is, and it's not kind of following
the random, random patterns that one would
expect if really our activity pattern would
be derived by randomness. Now, of course,
no one expects that their activity pattern
is random so that's never a question. I don't
think that I'm acting randomly and I hope
none of you acts random, either. But the question
from the scientific perspective is that what
are the signatures from the norm-, from those
normal randomness? And burstness is one of
the signatures. And burstness actually takes
us to the next question, which I already outlined
here. I said, "If we were to understand humans
the way we understand natural phenomena, we
should be able to predict their activity."
Now, prediction is really a very scary word
by itself because the question is what are
we going to predict? Am I going to try to
predict what you're going to dream about tonight?
Or, will I predict when will you get the next
promotion? Or a chance encounter with somebody
and so on. And as I mentioned earlier, in
order to predict anything we need data--lots
of data. So, a litmus test of our ability
to predict human behavior really rests on
our ability to collect data about some aspects
of human behavior; then we can use later to
say how predictable it is. So, when we started
thinking about this problem several year ago,
I thought, "Let's collect data about human
mobility; where we are, where we go next."
So, I actually, not having access to any other
data, I was so curious whether we are predictable
or not that I decided to collect data about
myself. So, I started to wear this tiny, sexy
watch that was really a conversation piece
at any single dinner that I went to because
it was standing out as a big brick on my hand.
[laughter]
But what it did, essentially, is that it's
really designed for runners and anybody else
who's involved in other sports that needs
to track their location in time, and what
it does is it tracks in real time where you
are and at the end of the day you can put
it into the computer and you get, essentially,
your trajectory. So, in my case, I got a map
like that. So, here's how I'm moving around
Boston so I can disclose my location because
this is mine. And, and the question that I
wanted to ask with this data that if I have
access to my past whereabouts, could I write
an algorithm that would tell me where I'm
going to be tomorrow at 3pm? Not that I really
care about where I'm gonna be tomorrow at
3pm. I should know better than that, but that's
really a test of how well we understand, essentially,
some aspects of human behavior, like human
mobility. But as we're, as we're kind of collecting
data I realize that there is already lots
of location data collected by individuals
because -- is there anybody in this room who
does not have a mobile phone? Ok, nobody's
raising their hand. So, and of course, nope,
you're not kidding yourself in this particular
institution about the fact that your mobile
phone company knows exactly where you are
at any moment. So, and, and not only do they
know where you are and that's normally not
collected, but for billing purposes, every
time you make a phone call that data is actually
being collected. So, so the mobile phone company
knows not only where you are, but it knows
where millions of other consumers. So, this
is much richer data than what I could ever
collect about myself because it allows us
to compare many, many individuals and, of
course, mobile phone companies are terribly
worried about releasing some of this data
as you very well know here because they wanna,
they wanna protect the data for keeping the
trust of their consumers and also for legal
reasons and so on. But in the last few years
they realized that there's lots of value in
this data, so they started to raise it for
researchers, for other companies and my group
happened to be one of those that we were given
quite large scale data about human mobility
and calling patterns--of course, anonymized
we don't know who the users are, we don't
know their phone numbers, we just know, they
are for us, they are just particles wandering
in space like a bromium particle in a gas.
And this really kind of allowed us to ask
the question: How predictable we are? So,
lemme give you an idea what is the amount
of data that one can actually get from that.
And what you see, of course, is a visualization
of the wonderful city of Paris, of how people
move around Paris, thanks to their mobile
phone data. And when you see this firework-like
type of jumps out there it doesn't really
mean that lots of mobile phone consumers jump
up in the sky and came back, but it just really
meant that in order to visualize the high
number of people going from one location to
another one, the next street, they really
had to move them out of space, essentially,
out of the flat space because otherwise you
wouldn't see the huge amount of activity that
is taking place over there. So, this kind
of gives you an idea of, of how much we know
about these individuals and once you have
access to the data, you can really start asking
the legitimate question: Is this behavior
predictable? Now, one of the questions we
first asked in a series of papers is that
what are distances that people travel on a
daily basis; how far you move around? And
the answer was relatively simple. If you look
at how many individuals move a certain distance,
this is the, this is the typical distance
car-, travel by, let's say, a person in a
big period versus the, how many people travel
that much, you find that most individuals
tend to stay local; that they just move two
to five kilometers on a daily basis. So, they
have a reduce of movement that is relatively
small, but of course, there are a few people
out there at the tail of the distribution
that move a lot. And the number of individuals
who move a little and versus those who move
a lot follows a very precise power law. So,
again, it's, it's, if you have a large population
you can predict how many people will be big
travelers, work travelers and how many will
be just sticking around in the neighborhood,
moving next door, essentially, to work from
their home and so on. So, this was kind of
the first step. And it already indicated there
was a lot of heterogametic in the population;
people behave quite differently if you look
at the large population. The next thing we
did is that we used this trajectory to measure
the entropy of each individual. That is, for
each person we measure the entropy of the
trajectory. Now, what is entropy? The entropy
of this particular system is zero. It says
that there is completely order system. You
know exactly where each ball is; there is
no ambiguity about each ball's position so
that's why we say "from our perspective it
has zero entropy." Now, this is a system how
it looks like if it is a disordered system
and that would have some kind of larger entropy
clearing on zero because it's random. So,
the entropy is a measure of randomness in
that respect, but the reason why we, we measured
entropy is because entropy is connected to
predictability. Lemme show you what I mean.
If I remove a ball--sorry--and, and you look
at this, you say, "Because the entropy of
the system is zero, you have absolutely no
ambiguity about where the use-, about where
the ball is missing from." You know exactly
the position of the ball that is missing from
there. What, so if I put it back I give you
no new information; very predictable. However,
if I show you this configuration then you
have no way of really knowing where I removed
that particle from. So, if the entropy of
the system is not zero, then it's much harder
to predict. And the same to our, to our trajectory.
If I measure your trajectory, my trajectory,
if I get a very, very low entropy it means
that we're very predictable. If I get a very
high entropy I have lots of problems predicting
where you're gonna be next time. So, what
we, what was our expectation? So, first of
all, we, we're able to derive from entropy
a measure of predictability and the predictability
in this case goes between number zero and
one. So, this is horizontally is this high
predictability and zero means is that the
user is completely, it's impossible to predict.
It's completely random, his or her motion.
And the predictability would be one if I could,
if one could, in principle, write a data mining
algorithm that, based on the past locations,
could a hundred percent accuracy predict their
next location. So, there will be no randomness
whatsoever in the persons motion. He or she
goes always exactly the same time back and
forth between home and work, for example.
So, our expectation was that because there
is this big heterogametic in the way we behave
and we move around, as we showed earlier in
the distances, we would find that most people
are difficult to predict because they happen
to have a life and they are somewhat spontaneous
and so on. And there may be a few people that
are somewhat easier to predict. So, that was
kind of where our starting point, that there
will be this kind of spectrum of behavior.
So then we measured the entropy for each user
and then we measured from that the predictability.
And on this plot, the predictability looked
like that. So, what is it that we see here?
Essentially, this is the predictability across
a large number of users who use mobile phones.
And the first thing you notice is that it's,
it's not a small number, but it's a very large
number. It's peaked around .93, which means
that, for a typical person, if you know their
past locations in principle with a 93 percent
accuracy, you can predict their next, their
next location, which is a huge amount of predictability
across the population and when it comes to
their next location. What is also interesting
about this curve is that there is nobody under
80 percent. That is, we always think that
there are, so in reality we are all very predictable,
we're missing essentially the people who don't
have really a high predictability and really
what is surprising is we tend to think that--ok,
fine. I happen to be a regular fellow. I go
always to work in the morning or, in my case,
at noon and I come back in the evening and
I have my favorite cafeterias and I follow
that path every day and so on. But there are
these other cool people around me.
[laughter]
The students and the rockers and so on who
are really cool and they are really unpredictable.
They are spontaneous. They're really living
out there. Well, what this curve tells you
is that that person may seem cool to you,
but is probably only five percent less predictable
than you are.
[everyone laughs]
So, I don't want to put it in terms that we
are all boring, but when it comes to our predictability
or at least our locations, it is, it is actually
the case. At least that's what the data is
showing to us.
[audience member laughs]
So, why am I bringing this example up and
why did I put this one in the book? Is because
I was really trying to show that once you
can collect enough data about people you can
really ask this fundamental question how predictable
we are and you get really surprising answers,
which kind of if one interpolated into the
future, could say, "Is it possible that just
about any aspects of human behavior could
be predicted if we collect enough data?" And
that's really kind of a question, that is
a question of our times and I'm sure many
of you are thinking about it in this context
and, and the answer is very complex. And I
kind of try to advance this argument as I
move along the book is that where will this
essentially lead in the long term? So, kind
of closing the, the science part for a second
in the interest of time, the last aspect of
the book – it's kind of the last vehicle
to getting the message through -- is a very
nonconventional one because it has to do with
images. So, if you flip through the book you
will see images like that and these are the,
these are drawings and kind of like, it's
kind of using different media. It was done
by Botond Reszegh and Botond Reszegh is an
artist from Transylvania, from the village
where I'm from, essentially, from the city
where I'm from in Transylvania. And what he
and I had been working on for the last few
years while writing this book is that to,
I told you there are different layers in the
book: the history, the science, Hasan and
so on. So, every second chapter, essentially,
has an image like that, which tries to put
these different layers on top of each other.
It tries to marry the science with the history.
And this is a good example of that. This comes
before the chapter where we start to talk
about the historical, the historical moment
when the Pope election takes place in Rome
that starts the history aspects of the book
and, and hence, since that particular event
took place in the Sistine Chapel, we see,
we see kind of the image of God in front of
the Sistine Chapel. What is interesting is
that this particular event takes place a few
months after the painting of Michelangelo
was finished, so those electors who were actually
electing the next Pope probably could smell
the fresh paint on the wall because it was
just brand new; a few months old. And on top
of it you see a Brownian motion because I
talk in that particular chapter about the
possibility that we are random. And one aspect
of random mobility is that we move completely
randomly. That is, that we move like a random
particle and you kind of see a Brownian trajectory
over there. So, as I mentioned, every second
chapter has--and I think these are beautiful
images that Botond Reszegh has done--and kind
of the concept of bursts in essence marry-,
married with, with some of the battles that
took place in the the event, the concept of
chance and weather predictability on the top
and at the same time showing the historical
location of some of the events that took place
in the history line. And, and the last reason
why, and this one actually is one of my favorites,
once again, on the top those criss-crosses
essentially show the trajectory of mobile
phone users, as is recorded by mobile phone
companies where they are based on their phone
calls. And what you see in the latter, essentially,
is a key letter in the historical line because
it reveals who is the character--who is the
main character--of the historical story. And
this letter was written about seven years
before the events took place in Transylvania
and one of, and, and I actually travelled
quite a bit to find that particular letter
and the reason why this was particularly interesting
for me is it was written actually by Leonard
Barabasi who happens to be one of my ancestors
who was the viceroy of Transylvania, so, the
second person after the king at that time.
So, he himself was very personally involved
and through him, essentially, our family was
very involved in much of the events of 1514.
So, it's not a completely independent story.
The reason why I picked it is because it has
lots of personal relevance, just like the
science in the book because if I wanna conclude
I wanna say in many ways this was a very personal
book because I don't -- I try to write about
things that I care about that involves the
science part, the type of research that we
do in my group about predictability, about
human behavior, about complication of social
science and the history like also follows
my personal interest in that respect. And
my goal was in this book is to kind of combine
these different narratives together and it
will be up to you to decide how successful
that attempt has been. Thank you very much
for attention.
[applause]
And I believe we have some time to take some
questions? Am I correct? I guess we have to
use that microphone so that it will be recorded
for posterity, or whatever you say, in the
spirit of this talk.
[Albert laughs}
And the spirit of the book. Yes.
>>audience member#1: Hi. You mentioned predicting
people's location. I was wondering what granularity
that was at?
>>Albert: Oh. So, the work we have done, essentially,
we entirely use only the tower level data.
So, so, so, we know exactly where users are
when they make a phone call and, and only
what is the tower they are closest at. So,
what we--
>>audience member#1: So, is that typically
like a half mile or?
>>Albert: Well, it depends on the, on the
region, obviously. In big cities, it could
be a few hundred meters, essentially, a quarter
of a mile, even shorter. In, so the, so the
density is very, very high in big cities like
New York City and becomes much lower when
you go out of that. Yes, that's right, but
the majority of the users that we looked at
happened to be in the big cities because that's
where people are. So, in that respect we have
quite a bit of resolution, but yes, indeed.
In principle, we also chunked the time into
hour long intervals because there's really
not much of a [ ] where you'll be maybe five
minutes from now. It's more like in hourly
intervals so, so at the end, a temporal regularity,
temporal chunks are on hour and the location
resolution is the tower distance.
>>audience member#1: Thanks.
>>Albert: Mm-hmm.
>>audience member #2: Hi. You talked about
trying to understand people. There's this
stupid flatworm called C. elegans where we
know the complete circuit diagram; every cell
and every neuron and yet people have not been
able to build a complete simulator of this
worm. So, I look at that and I say, "We're
very far away from being able to predict individual
people." We can predict statistical things
and that's quite different. Have you ever,
I don't know if you've seen the book, "Human
Behavior and the Principle of Least Effort",
by Zipf in 1949 where he tried to predict
mass behavior, but I look at this specific
simulations and I say, "We can't even do a
flatworm." People have also tried to do the
garden slug and again, they know the wiring
diagram and they can't tell you what the slug
will do.
>>Albert: It's, it's a lovely question. Essentially,
is that, I mean I think that your question
has many, many -- raises many, many issues.
The flatworm, C. elegans, is one of my favorites,
essentially. I have published quite a number
of papers on that. I know, I don't know if
you know, that you can knock out a particular
gene and then you would make it to make all,
only in circles and circles and circles. So,
so, we understand lots about that, but--
>>audience member #2: You mean the Indianapolis
Race Course?
[Albert laughs]
>>Albert: That's right, that's right. It becomes
a car racer, that's right. But, on the other
hand, the, the question you are really raising
is that what is the type of data? Can we really
understand something from fundamentals? Physicists
have been very kind of arrogant in that respect
to say if we understand elementary particles
we can tell you everything what you're gonna
do next. And that's not the case. So, in the
sense that really, I mean, there are these
different resolutions of how we understand,
essentially, in the world and one of the,
and I think most of us in sciences have given
away that particular possibility that in my
understanding quantum mechanics elementary
particles we're gonna understand how our brain
works. But what is really happening is that
at different levels of resolution we can really
measure certain aspects of behavior and they,
by themselves, can be predictable. So, I may
not understand fully the full quantum mechanics
of how a electron moves exactly in let's say,
one particular metal, but I can make a chip,
a pretty good chip about it and I can predict
very well the chip's behavior when it comes
to computation. And in the same way, I think
what happens about human behavior is that
we do not understand really from, let's say,
from neuron level why we do things and so
on, but certain behavior aspects of ours are
really fundamentally predictable and the data
is really telling us that is possible – the
possibility. And, I think, if anything I can
hope from this research is that we will start
asking systematically what aspects of human
behavior are part of that category that can
be predicted and what aspects of that would
never be predictable, essentially, given the
amount of data we can collect of them, partly
because they happen too rarely to find any
patterns about them and partly because they
inherently have such a large entropy, for
example, that, that they're predictable if
it will be zero. And I think it's all up to
us all in this environment is really ripe
for that to ask these questions across many
behavior patterns. Thank you.
>>audience member #3: Thank you, Dr. Albert,
for your presence. It's fantastic, fascinating
chart indeed. My question is like, the minute
that someone says "predict," the notion that
I get in my mind is predicting some form of
an event like a 9/11 happening, some kind
of event, right? And what I've really kind
of gathered from your research is predicting
human location--
>>Albert: Sure.
>>audience member #3: like, where they are,
where they're going to be. So how will you
kind of connecting that locational prediction
to some kind of event that might take place.
Have you made that, that bridge? Do you know
what I mean?
>>Albert: The answer simply is no. And I,
I think we're very, very far from that, but
we're at the moment we can actually ask that
question whether that's possible or not. You
are very right. Everything that I refer to
here, refers to habitual events; things we
do, things we do with certain amount of regularity
that we can actually collect data about that.
But I think that's the only way to proceed
at this stage. Let's first understand habitual
events. Let's understand the type of things
that we do and occupies 93 percent of our
time because the reason why we can predict
93 percent accuracy is because we spend a
huge bulk of our time at home and at work
and travelling in-between and there is very
little time in-between to do something crazy,
in that respect, in something different. And
I think once we understand the habitual events,
which I call the normal behavior patterns,
then we can start asking systematical the
question how we can predict, essentially,
the event that differ from normal. And 9/11
is an event that differs from normal. Could
we get there? Right now, I say, "It's hopeless."
We cannot collect enough data to predict 9/11
in that respect, another 9/11. But, on the
other hand, I think that we have to walk systematically
this path through the small details all the
way to the big picture in order to get there
and give a precise answer.
>>audience member #3: Great. That's very interesting.
So, am I to, am I right in understanding that
your thought is, rather your research, is
on the premise that most of the things that
happen in the future has a very tangible link
to some data point that happened in the past?
It could be location; it could be something
else which you have not yet researched as
yet.
>>Albert: Oh, I believe that and I think,
I think, think about the weather patterns,
for example. In 1800 and this is one of the
things I talk about in the book, the way,
you know what? England was actually pretty
good at predicting about the weather. And
the way they did it, and up to like 1960s,
was that every day the weather map would come
in, what are the weather in the morning and
around UK and then the weatherman would look
around, essentially, and say, "I remember.
Four years ago in April was we had exactly
the same pattern. It was very, very similar.
Let's pull out that map." So they said, "Oh,
yeah. This is just like that." So let's pull
out the next day's map from four years ago
and we say if the weather is today like four
years ago, then it's gonna continue next day
that way. And it was relatively predictive
in that respect. How did we get today to the
very precise prediction that a few hours ahead
we are very accurate about the weather? By
collecting a huge amount of data about the
weather patterns, essentially. So, once that
data converged, that is, that we had enough
resolution in the data collection and in the
computational tools, then weather prediction
became rather accurate and we also understood
the limits of how we can go. It's about 19
days how we can advance, how we can predict
in the future because there's a chaotic limit
that we are hitting that the instabilities
are too, the normalarities are too strong
and you cannot go beyond that even if you
have enough data. I think that's the type
of understanding we seek about human behavior.
How far we can go in advance and what is the
limit of predictability? And I believe that
there will be a limit of predictability. For
human mobility, it's quite long because we
are very regular. For some other aspects,
like 9/11, maybe very, very short.
>>audience member #3: Thank you.
>>Albert: Thank you.
>>audience member #4: Hi. My question is about
also to predicting locations and you're, you're
talking about habits and you're saying most
people are regular, but did you see any events
or what about the number of people who like,
just stuff that happens out of habit like,
you get arrested, they go to jail, you spend
time in jail, you get in an accident, they
go to the hospital or they get deployed to
Iraq.
>>Albert: Yes.
>>audience member #4: These kind of things.
Do you see these people and do they fall within
that 20 percent that you talked about?
>>Albert: It's a very good question and the
question is where is the seven percent coming
from that we are failing to predict, that's
also part of it. And it's undeniable that
we have major life changes and when you get
hired in Google, for example, you change fundamental
your behavior of what you did before, if you
were a student or something before. We marry,
we divorce, we move jobs, we move houses and
so on and that changes, essentially, our,
our mobility pattern. The question is what
percentage of your time at any moment is really
reflecting that change? And the, the fact
is that after the change you enter in another
habitual pattern that is very predictable.
So, for example, you mention someone in jail.
Hey. Somebody's in jail is very predictable.
It's gonna be in jail for a couple of years.
[laughter]
So, so, in that respect, I think part of the
unpredictability comes from the people who
we see, this is the kind of on average end
and those who are on the lower end in predictability
are people who may have actually had a change
of lifestyle during the period that we were
looking at. They may have moved location and
so on. So, this is part of the picture, absolutely.
But I think we tend to underappreciate the
time that we actually spend on habitual patterns
and how little is actually the transition
time from one to another one. And once you
have the transition, then you switch to another
one. So, I think that's where, that's why
we don't get a hundred percent.
>>audience member #4: Thanks.
>>audience member #5: So, the fifth part of
your natural science or human diagram is control.
So, what do you think the implications of
your work are for controlling people's behavior,
location, or other aspects that you think
you can measure and get enough data about?
>>Albert: I mean, that's a lovely question
and it's a very pertinent question and let
me tell you again an example from the weather
patterns. So, everybody has heard of John
van Neumann, essentially and he's a really
big developing the first computer, not only
in architecture, but in building the first
computer. Few of you may know the fact of
why he actually got the money to do that--from
the military. Because he proposed that he
will predict weather and he will control the
weather. And they had like this crazy images
of how they are gonna control. They gonna
spray chemicals around the weather and disperse
clouds and so on and, of course, they never
got to that, but they got to the, it was thanks
to John Neumann that first time the Meteorological
Agency of US has purchased a computer to start
predicting weather and that's what, that's
why we have it. So, luckily they never got
to control and I'm just hoping that this will
be the same case as well, here. And I think
one of the goal I had with this book is let's
just talk openly about these issues. Because
I think we, as a society, have to come together
and decide how far we wanna push it. And I
think Google is struggling this question very,
very much both internally, I'm sure externally,
which we see very much of how, how we find
this balance essentially between the usefulness
for me and the, and the, at least the perception
of control about, about my, about what I do.
And I think that the only way we can actually
arrive to, to where it's situational, to where
we don't kill innovation, but we also maintain
privacy and, and kind of lower the fear level
is by talking openly about that. So, to be
shorter, essentially, I think we're everybody's
very far away from thinking seriously about
control. But we have to realize that's the
natural progress of understanding processes,
but, but control is a question of will. And
will can be controlled by loss, can be controlled
by consensus and we can control that control,
essentially, we can limit control only by
understanding what it could lead. And I think
that's why I put it there, that let's just
get it open out there. Let's, let's think
about it and let's come together and decide
where the limits of that one are.
>>audience member #5: Thank you.
>>Albert: Sure.
>>audience member #6: You talked about having
like a huge amount of data and then from that,
extrapolating with 93 percent accuracy a person's
location in the future and I was wondering
if having all of that data, was the reason
you were able to do that? Or if you had data,
just solely one user, would your set of prediction
algorithms work just as well, just for that
single person?
>>Albert: Well, I think it would have worked
just as well for one person except nobody
would have really believed we could predict
and the referees would have never believed
that I got something generic here. They just
have thought that I just got a very peculiar
user who's very boring, irregular. So, I think
from my perspective as a physicist, I always
ask the question, "The result that I get,
how generic it is?" If I can only predict
you, everybody will kind of jump at me and
say, "You are a very special case." And of
course you are a very special case, but if
I want to show the generic results, I have
to do that for everybody in this room and
not only in this room, but I have to look
at non-Google employees as well and people
who go to school and people who live under
the bridge and so on. And, and at the end
of the day, that was the reason why we have
to have this different data is to really understand
how limited is the understanding we get from
this data. How particular it is for one person?
And even in this case you may ask, "Is it
really just referring to the country where
the data is from?" And I think that we believe
that this is rather generic, it's not particular
to one country. You may ask other questions.
What is the demographic spectrum of the people
we use? And of course, that's limited by the
people who use cell phones as well, but in
this case actually, the country has 110 percent
penetrational cell phones. That there are
ten percent more subscriptions than how many
people are in the country; so therefore, we
think that we get a pretty good demographic.
So, I think the main reason we look for lot,
many people is to convince ourselves and the
community that this is a generic result and
not particular to you or I.
>>audience member #6: Thanks.
>>Albert: Ok.
>>audience member #7: In the location data
that you got from the cell phone companies,
were you able to actually correlate like street
closures and other events that actually caused
habitual travel to, to change? The reason
I bring this up is because there's enough
traffic analysis as a civil engineer where
we try to control how populations move by
building roads, destroying roads, things like
that.
>>Albert: Sure. Now, let me, you're, you're
right on the money in the sense that one of
the reasons I, I personally believe we need
to understand this, the type of travel patterns
is to be able to build better cities and that's
part of it, building better roads and so on.
We have a project now that we're trying to
do that, but the data we get, essentially,
is inherently limiting in that respect because
we know only when the person makes a phone
call where they are only in the tower resolution.
Now, on the other hand, I believe that, that
we could actually extract some of the anomalies
in the mobility that you're talking about.
And we have a project now where we're trying
to do that by first building up a map of the
regular mobility pattern of what is, what
is the predicted one and trying to see if
there are any significant deviations from
that and we hope to look into the, into the
media as well, to detect some of these events
that we know that took place and correlate
with that and see how detectable we are. The
results so far were not encouraging. I think
the data collection is very sparse. In order
to do that I think you need to get the type
of data that, that resulted in the Paris visualization
that really recorded every time a user passed
from one tower to another type of region where
either he or she made a phone call or not.
So, that's kind of the, the pass through data
and we don't have regulatory access to the
data because normally what phone companies
do not collect that, but they could and they
did for, for that particular visualization
project. If we would have that, then I think
the resolution would be possible.
>>audience member #6: Thanks.
>>Albert: Thanks. So, it's a matter of data.
[Albert laughs]
>>audience member #7: I'm wondering if you've
ever read Isaac Asimov's Foundation series?
>>Albert: Why do you think I work on this
project?
[laughter]
>>audience member #7: Yeah, I mean, ok. So,
did you take some inspiration from that. There's
this science called "psychohistory" and--
>>Albert: Sure, in Harry Seldon, that's right.
[laughter]
Of course just to tell you, I don't think
we're any close to that and you remember why
he was successful at predicting the future?
What, what was the price for that?
>>audience member #7: I think he got to build
a encyclopedia, or funding for his encyclopedia.
>>Albert: Sure, but that have noble, but it
was actually something that had to happen
in order to be predictive. They had to stop
every innovation.
>>audience member #7: All right.
>>Albert: So, absolutely science was outlawed
and there could be no innovations. So, essentially,
they had to maintain this stationary state
of the society where no new Google would ever
come along. So, so in that respect, I, I really
think that that's where I say that there may
be a certain amounts of days, of months, of
years of limitation of how far you can go
and that's one of the goal of this is to say
what type of events? How far into the future
could we predict it? And, and the -- Asimov
was actually a smart person and he realized
that if you allow for innovation, predictability
will pretty much go to zero on long time because
how well could you have predicted twenty years
ago the impact of Google on the society? Hopeless.
Am I correct? I mean, look at the 1960s visions
of how the 2000 is gonna look like and you're
laughing about it. It's like a fairy tale,
isn't it? We are all flying in personal rockets
around the earth and we have no Internet or
concept that we don't have a personal computer
concept of one? So, how different is our reality
from what we imagined back then? And that's
thanks to innovation. And thanks to innovation,
taking a different path from what could be
predicted based on what people cared about
back then, which they cared about space travel,
so, so therefore, they projected their future
based on space travel and not on what they
could not have imagined, which is the Information
Revolution. So, so that's why I, I think that
Harry Seldon will never become a reality,
only at the price where we stop essentially.
So, maybe you could do that in North Korea.
[laughter]
So, perhaps this is a good moment for us to
end? Thanks for your attention. Thank you
for attention.
[laughter]
[applause]